[Musique]
alors silence en studio l'émission temps
plan canada avait commencé aujourd'hui
la date du 25 octobre 2019 jeudi pour
ceux qui auraient hiberné pour encore
qui serait rendue vers mars comme ça qui
aurait été mis en congélation prolonger
ça va arriver un jour je me suis
certainement on va être diffusée non
seulement à travers le monde sait qu
actuellement mais à travers le système
solaire et on n'est pas encore maquiller
malgré le fait que la brouille 30 31
les bons sujets de reportage alors
autour de la table on a tout à dire une
gagne oui c'est ça on n'a jamais eu 100
studios d'abord une première que vous
soyez quatre ans plus de l'invité
principal animateur vous n'avez jamais
et participe à des missions avec moi
dans le sang moi non plus non plus d'un
mois note concernant l'autre duo on n'a
jamais eu et c'est l'émission ça c'est
d'être dus aux probables dans tout le
monde voulait venir à l'émission
aujourd'hui on a dû refuser les
attendant la porte alors écouter
sérieusement vous connaissez la règle
rémission n'y en a pas mais la plus
importante s'il y en avait une
c'est que vous ne connaissez pas
officiellement le chat j'ai sûrement
jamais mais dites moi soyons honnêtes
qui connaît la villanelle le sujet de
l'émission aujourd'hui sans dire moi
mais j'ai serré motus et bouche cousue
je resterai discret pas pour moi non
donc on se rend pas les dindons de la
farce simplement c'est comme une fuite
au bureau de dans un temple tout ce qui
est bien c'est qu'on a des internautes
avec nous et qui peuvent jouer le jeu de
la vidéo 5 images est en tête des
indices allant voir ces 2 2
alors alice ou et puis notre ami samir
ben vous pouvez jouer le jeu avec nos
internautes grimage on va essayer et
c'est pas facile cette semaine je vais
être d'accord d'avoir de la difficulté
cracher sur pense à ces le c'est un
homme d'affaires très connu à dakar a
dit oui mais récemment ça dit il
rené angelil et un jeune il avait donc
les analyses et le monde
pallanca chanteur canadien alors voilà
je vous ai vraiment avoir doigt jeudi
mouawad donc là on est dans un des dents
des prix quelque chose comme ça et puis
ces gens là ont quelque chose en commun
ils parlent et east eh ben il ya le
riche de huit heures festives sont les
canadiennes d'origine origines à aa
j'aurais juste pour moi en rade le
langage est pas j'ai pas fait du tout le
même magnifique voix de paul anka qui
arrivait de changer le nom je te parmi
les plus grandes chansons qui ont été
les plus populaires aux états unis voilà
c'est de savoir comment je sais que ces
gens là sont d'origine arabe
c'est que j'étais sur le site de radio
canada international et on a un dossier
spécial spatiale spatiale alors en inde
où ces spéciales sur le monde arabe au
canada et d'ailleurs on va s'amuser
ensemble aujourd'hui à découvrir ce
monde puisque le festival est une
occasion non seulement découvrir les
facettes artistiques mais aussi
politique de cette intégration
culturelle qui continue au canada pas de
jour de façon aisée surtout depuis les
événements de 2001 d'accord voilà pour
la thèse munitions on va présenter cette
première question parce qu'à trois
questions à l'émission vous devez tous
essayer de gagner de le perdre de moins
pour un possible on appelle ça déboule
cette émission il ya trois jeux et pour
le premier jeu matthew vous connaissez
combien de bol ou de risquer de perdre
20 20 exactement c'est gênant j'ai gagné
des points bonus y pense c'est vous le
cervelas il ya deux boutons non voilà
c'est parti on affiche à l'écran pendant
des internautes
et pour vous aussi je passe que une
petit peu petit préambule une analyse de
l'institut canadien aux arabes réalise
en 2014 disait qu'il y avait près de 750
et canadiens d'origine arabe au canada
sur une population de 36 millions da kg
minata maintenant la question en quelle
année est arrivé au canada le premier
ministre d'origine
là tout le monde peut répondre moi vas-y
1792 1880 2009 142 ou encore ma préférée
aucune de ces réponses moche avec 1900
gérer pour lober le jeu on l'avait
ensuite 1880 sait pas encore d'où le
canada canada n'existait pas moi
j'hésite entre 1792 ou 1890 parce que
j'ai animé une émission à une époque qui
fait le pont entre le maghreb et canada
alors j'ai dit mais je pense que je vais
me rallier oui on va aller pour 82 je
pense qu'il est arrivé n'était parti
bout s'était depuis des pays du le pays
du levant je pense qu'ils sont venus de
syrie ou du liban où tu dis on va
espérer ça aujourd'hui on va alors voir
avec mélissa 82 répondait l'année car il
vit sa 90 alice 1942 sa 1882 et puis
matthew 1882 qui a répondu 1882 trois 3
personnes sur 4
alors il n'y a que 20 boules qui sont
perdus pour ce premier tour ses 10 ans
en 1942 c'est sûr que là on est rendu
aux douves n'étaient pas écoutés ils
venaient du liban ça mais à l'époque ça
c'était pas le liban nous ne vendrons ça
s'appelait jupe à l'expérience marc
géographie ça parce que c'était des
territoires qui étaient hautement
comment ça va contester territoire
autonome au sein de l' empire ottoman
qui s'étalait jusqu'à la perse japon ça
faisait partie du monde motta sa bio et
en français pourquoi pas sa méfiance et
indiens du
savoir les appartenances du de l'empiré
ottoman est-ce que la perse fait partie
de l'empiré ottoman non mais la porte
est et en turquie mais mes forces je
m'aperçois laporte temps de l'empiré
ottoman c'est la turquie oui d'ailleurs
actuellement c'est le renouveau ottoman
mais non non je ne pense pas que la
personne peut demander à notre service
technique qui est responsable de la
diffusion de cette émission et de son
contenu en partie sur l'internet
peut-être donner la réponse est alors
plus tard beaucoup plus tard on va aller
vers notre invité skype aujourd'hui et
il s'agit d'une jeune personne mathias
ollivier qui est le porte parole du
festival du monde arabe un organe 20e
édition bonjour mathias bonjour ça va
très bien bonjour mathias vous vous avez
bon vous avez un peu plus que maintenant
mais à peine j'ose dire votre festival à
20 ans lui alors oui je suis arrivé très
jeune au festival qu'est ce qui fait de
vous aujourd'hui porte parole du
festival comment vous avez cumulé ses
galons et vous vous retrouvez à cette
émission à écouter une implication
totale depuis cinq années en fait on
touche à tout j'ai commencé à la vidéo
est maintenant je suis à adjoint à la
direction artistique j'ai dossier la
communication je suis très investi en
fête au festival s'est il s'agit aussi
d'un sentiment d'appartenance est plus
qu'un travail
on va passer une bande annonce de votre
festival je les trouve extrêmement bien
faite
on a trouvé ça sur youtube on va
chercher où on peut hein pas de budget
alors surtout l'été
alors on présente ça et on y voit des
artistes tout à fait extraordinaire
c'est très bien fait cesser on appelle
ça aujourd'hui une autre vidéo de 0,2
d'accord vidéo au numéro 2 on s'enferme
pas dans les grandes c'est ici à bâle
par contre ça qui attendez vous cette
année au festival
mais aujourd'hui on attend l'ouverture
en fait aujourd'hui on a un spectacle
s'appelle et la femme chante à dieu qui
réunit en fait trois chanteuses qui vont
chanter les trois monothéismes des
chants juifs méchants musulmans et des
chants chrétiens
ça c'est pour l'ouverture sinon c'est
toujours une pléiade d'artistes qui
honore en fait les cultures l'héritage
des cultures arabes au sens large là
mais aussi les nouvelles générations
donc on pourrait rentrer en détail mais
le festival s'est toujours efforcé en
fait à faire revivre l'héritage des
siècles voire millénaire en fait pu
aussi à montrer en fait qu'est-ce que
les nouvelles propos les nouvelles
générations propose à l'iss mathias
ollivier en tant que porte parole de ce
festival laquelle sont les principaux
messages je vous entends des véhicules
et écouter la voix quand j'entends le
message là j'entends politique j'entends
militantisme mais le festival n'est pas
un acteur politique qui peut faire de la
politique dans le sens où on participe à
la cité on participe à la ville qu'est
ce qui se passe dans la société mais on
n'a pas de message politique clair nous
ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est justement
déjà de faire connaître cette culture
plurielle composite et qui traverse les
âges et amener justement les gens qui
peuvent être différents à se rencontrer
en fait parce que on peut regrouper
autant le public québécois que ceux qui
se revendiquent de ces cultures comme
d'autres publics en fait oui vous dites
qu'il n'ya pas de message politique mais
le titre cette année du festival est
tout à fait particulier parlez-nous la
décision pourquoi vous avez choisi de
lui donner ce thème là alors juste en
préambule pour vous dit en fait le
festival s'est toujours démarqué parce
qu'il est un festival non seulement on
est le premier festival du monde arabe
en amérique
une heure mais aussi parce qu'on propose
des thématiques comme pour susciter la
réflexion chez le spectateur le public
même ceux qui n'y vont pas là il pouvait
entendre parler du festival
donc nous on veut toujours interpeller
les gens mais pas au sens politicien du
terme et en fait l'édition de cette
année pour ses 20 ans c'est 20 ans
d'acrobaties aux midis du monde
c'était un titre assez poétique mais qui
veut dire qu'en fait à notre vingtième
année à l'heure où on va dire qu'on est
pris entre deux plaques le monde arabe
et l'occident qui semblent s'affronter
se lancer chacun un miroir culpabilisant
nous on est là entre les deux et on se
sont hélas lucide on n'a pas d'illusions
on est on est pas dans on n'est pas dans
l'idéalisme dans le mythe on est
réaliste sans être dans le déclin donc
nous on se rend compte de cette chose là
c'est que on est entre ces deux mondes
qui se renvoient la balle
il y a aussi des conséquences réelles et
lourdes à sa par exemple l'on a on est
soutenue par les trois conseils des arts
québec montréal fédéral canada et
pourtant la province du québec nous a
lâchés à hauteur de 200 mille dollars en
quelques années à peine sans nous avoir
prévenus ni justifier la raison donc
c'est une vraie juste pour terminer
c'est une façon pour nous de faire un
bilan et n'est pas dans les chais clé
dans le réalisme et de continuer à faire
ce qu'on fait donc 20 ans intervient
aussi de mon côté donc vingt ans après
le festival se retrouve à court de
financement de la part du gouvernement
du québec c'est ça oui c'est on le on le
dit pour que ça se sache
ouais et après le québec nous a soutenus
par le passé on aimerait qu'ils
continuent à nous soutenir nous pensons
que c'est important
juste pour terminer par rapport à hautem
et au public et on nous demande qui en
fait projette il ya beaucoup de gens qui
projette dans le festival c'est le
festival du monde arabe et les gens qui
sont politisés ou qui ont des idées
fixes ou reçus en fait voir en nous
l'étendard de leurs ennemis politiques
et idéologiques alors qu'on est un
festival purement culturel et cherche
justement à montrer la culture
juste je reviens vous avez parlé au
début de rencontre festival de
rencontres
quand on part de rencontre est-ce que
vous avez des des spectateurs des
surtout je parle de spectacle ou
d'activités qui regroupe entre monde
arabe et québec où canada ou bien
l'occident en général oui ben écoutez on
fait ça depuis 20 ans en fait le premier
spectacle qui me vient en tête c'est une
création du festival de 2009 2010 je
sais que je pense pour à l'occasion du
10ème anniversaire c'est un spectacle
s'appelle je me souviens et qui était en
fait la rencontre entre la danse date
et puis la tradition québécoise en fait
donc le festival c'est toujours forcés à
trouver des liens parce que justement
nous c'est ça qu'on aime faire qu'on
aime trouver c'est dresser des
passerelles entre les mondes sans
écarter les différences mais aussi en
voyant qu est ce qui nous réunit en quoi
les différences la culturellement
parlant sont intéressantes et
enrichissantes
ou tout simplement belle parce qu'il
s'agit de culture d'art salle au milieu
de la politique
si sylvain le public qui vient assister
à ce festival ça fait vingt ans
maintenant à ce que ses croissants et
quel genre de public vient voir ce
festival est ce que vous attendez plus
de monde cette année
pour cette année nous attendons ça va
justement être l'occasion de prendre la
température mais le festival a connu des
hauts et des bas en fait il y a eu des
événements disons médiatico-politique
qui ont eu des retombées sur le festival
il ya eu deux événements cruciaux il ya
eu d'abord le 11 septembre 2001 où le
spectacle le festival était à peine
assez première année et malgré ce
terrible incident en fait le public
québécois et elle a à nouveau et les
salles étaient remplies le public
québécois composé à peu près 75 pour ça
en fait du public et à partir de 2007
qui est la deuxième match à revenir en
fait du festival il ya eu les
accommodements raisonnables les je ne
sais pas comment expliquer sinon
médiatiquement peut-être on sait pas
mais les québécois sont descendus à 7%
donc vous voyez il ya quand même une
humeur il y à il ya des conséquences et
nous on a toujours essayé de s'ajuster à
ça et c'est pourquoi aussi on essaye de
de stimuler le public qu'ils soient en
accord ou pas avec nous qu'ils croient
qu'on est soi même ni ou pas on utilise
nos thématiques en fait comme celle ci
cette année qui est un peu plus
anniversaire et un constat sur nous mais
on essaye de faire réagir les gens avec
des thématiques parfois provocatrices
parfois qu'il pousse à la réflexion on
avait à raismes lever les voiles et
érotique halal prophète rebelles ou
aussi hilare us délit russe qui pendant
le temps des décapitations en 2006 à
fait au point nommé car l'époque la
fiche avait fait polémique à l'époque
mais c'était bien pour la visibilité du
festival je me rappelle on voulait
susciter une réaction n'avait pas
c'était aussi là qu'on a pu voir à quel
point les gens pouvaient projeter en
août certains nous disaient vous êtes
des islamophobes d'autres me disais mais
en fait vous faites le jour des
occidentaux mais tant qu'on peut
susciter des réactions et faire
réfléchir les gens
ça nous va merci j'avais interviewé jeu
safina cris lorsqu'il avait reçu de
l'ordre l'ordre national du québec
il avait été décoré pour son travail au
fmi je m'explique mal que le nouveau
gouvernement ne soit pas sensible à ça
et qu on vous retire des fonds je ne
m'aventurerai pas tant sur le nouveau
gouvernement parce que en fait le
retrait de certains foncent à effectuer
avant l'arrivée de ce gouvernement
donc je vais pas extrapoler portée de
conclusion on fait juste remarquer ce
fait là il ya eu un retrait de la part
du gouvernement
on ne se sait pas encore comment
l'expliquer le fait d'un individu d'une
décision blazer d'un problème
administratif
on n'est pas au courant donc je n'irai
pas accuser le gouvernement actuel de
quoi que ce soit en fait puisqu'on peut
retracer ça avant l'arrivée de ce
gouvernement
alice en fait j'avais posé la question
de savoir si point les grandes
innovations de cette édition
anniversaire j'imagine que vous allez
penser à des choses tout à fait
originale pour attirer un plus grand
nombre de personnes oui mais avant de
parler des innovations je vais faire un
petit aperçu sur ce qu'est le festival
c'est assez complexe et quatre grands
volets en fait vous avez les arts de la
scène qui gravitent en général autour de
la place des arts avec des spectacles
périphérique vous avez des arts de la
scène aussi gratuit cette année par
exemple on a beaucoup de spectacles
gratuits qui reprennent beaucoup de nos
créations
parce que le festival s'efforce de créer
des spectacles originaux et qui ont sa
propre identité
il ya une revisite chacune de nos
créations où les plus grandes créations
à travers des artistes locaux c'est des
spectacles gratuits vous ai trouvé ça
sur internet et aussi on a un volet
cinéma et un volet conférences panel
pour justement pouvoir débattre voir des
films rencontrer des gens et parler avec
eux et pour revenir à votre question
en fait nous on renforce depuis quelques
années le volet création
on a cinq créations cette année en plus
de 20 spectacles j'imagine de la
programmation majeur et pour ses
spectacles là il y à l'ouverture et la
femme chante à dieu qui vient clôturer
en fait un triptyque consacré au sacré
il y avait le cercle de l'extase était
un succès immense là dans les années
2003 2004 puis dieu en 3d en 2011 il me
semble hélas et la femme chante à dieu
qui est un spectacle exclusivement
féminin avec plus de 25 femmes sur scène
où les trois monothéismes sont
rencontrés vient comme boucler la boucle
et en même temps lancé cette nouvelle
édition on a aussi d'autres spectacles
comme le abozekry project qui est en
fait la rencontre d'un jeune loup 10 tjp
siens qui est incroyable extraordinaire
et il va il veut il va à la rencontre
des meilleurs musiciens jazz de montréal
maintient aussi un autre spectacle un
hommage à une peau souple ou un
spectacle sur la syrie et justement
plutôt que de pas m'en parle beaucoup de
la syrie et on a tous une idée sur la
syrie en raison des atrocités convoi
nous on veut montrer l'aspect culturel
et cosmopolite pluriel de cette série
voilà on aperçut mathias moi je
je déteste la politique là je les
préoccupations très terre à terre est la
bonne poubelle renta nourriture on n'a
pas encore à sourire ce volet là on n'a
pas de cinquième volet là qui
l'interviewent les prix facturés
allemands pouvaient vont mourir de
musique de charles battu voix choses à
digérer
c'est la matière si le festival du monde
arabe de montréal était un édifice sont
simples c'est un locataire mêmes
propriétaires de condos depuis très
longtemps on est fier de vous avoir
comme porte parole vous avez fait un bon
travail aujourd'hui vraiment vous avez
un peu comme moi annales un coureur
automobile a fait du slalom il a tourné
les coins sont des appels est innocent
soit assez car si beaucoup matthias
pintscher merci à vous et moi
aujourd'hui c'est sans merci
mathias ollivier du festival du monde
arabe de montréal et l'importance dans
paris puisqu'il c'est le premier
incident du genre en amérique du nord
c'est pas simplement fête ses 20 ans
cette année ruelle à montréal chose
écoutez on est prêt pour vous présenter
notre deuxième tour de la grosse boule
avec nos sphères hologue qui active la
boule et puis combien de boules à perdre
mathieu 30
mathieu battu matthew mathieu maintenant
les peintres modernes fabien jettent à
discuter avec spatiale et matthew ça va
bien je sors un peu j'ai une voix
d'adolescent bon en tout cas ton affiche
ça pour tout le monde pour vous et pour
le peu le bénéfice de nos internautes
voici la deuxième grande question
on parlait à la syrie un instant je
trouve ça intéressant on a accueilli 25
me ce sens le canada
roman réfugiés ces six points alors le
plus grand groupe de canadiens d'origine
arabe en ce moment est originaire de
quel pays
est-ce que c'est à l'egypte b la série
c'est le maroc où aucune de ces réponses
et grand père est décédé sans prêtre
l'egypte parce que ces listes ou la
série je sais pas si on peut aussi en
train de voler en droit oui renchérit
pour l'egypte je pense en tant que
groupe je pense que si l'egypte n'est
qu'un jeu la raison il ya un creux
communauté marocaine aussi quand même
les je pense que mais il faut qu'il ya
beaucoup on vous parle de rien avec avec
l'histoire ce qui sont en lasse de
briller depuis longtemps donc je peux
groupe d'origine paradis et canal de
suez vient c1 obtenue au maroc depuis 67
il ya eu un groupe aussi mal géré pour
l'egypte vous avez pour l'egypte à leurs
familles avant pour les jeunes nés
quelque part je sais promet je serais
tentée moi aussi de parler de l'egypte
alice va oui si papa à sa cause les
projets nations historiques s'annonçait
c'est bien
j'aime beaucoup vos réponses et basé sur
un réseau national baril moi je vais
faire dissensions j'allais avec le maroc
maroc parce que on a un centre marc au
quai des arts et culture à montréal
c'est que l'ambassade marocaine est
peut-être très c'était très important
pour les débuts de la paix de saint tite
ce centre là je prends de chance mais
bon c'est pas une maison pas la bonne
raison même alex n'a pas répondu
[Musique]
mais là des jouets a évidemment alors
conserve ses boules et puis qui a aucun
répondu d aucune des crs à aucun de ses
membres on sait le liban le liban
premier 41% 41%
c'est énorme il vous avez les autres
statistiques l'egypte est sur une bonne
piste où l'egypte c'est ça
bah écoute et yann grande communauté ici
dans la légende noire
si vous êtes à montréal par exemple et
que votre voisin vous dit bonjour je
suis du liban ben écoutez c'est une
bonne chose là bas si vous voyez vous
disais sans être trop précis bonjour
savez je viens d'ailleurs je suis un
arabe et il arrête il y avait quatre
chances sur dix qu'ils sont des soins du
liban c'est quelque chose écouter mais
je voulais vous montrer parce que toute
cette science infuse qui m'habite moi je
là je la trouve dans le site de radio
canada international bien humblement
chaque semaine il ya tout un dossier sur
rendu à combien de points pour tout le
monde
sont-elles si important c'est la
participation des fois on a vidé au
numéro 7
pour montrer ce qu'assure la le site de
radio canada international si nous les
journées se ne connaissons pas de quoi
nous partons au moins le sait lui sait
de quoi il parle quand il voit ça on a
sept d'aussi je pense vous proposer ce
seuil il ya un livre de woods à la salle
kaki et les canadiens d'origine
votre article récent mari sur le
festival du monde qui s'élèvaient et
c'est ce soir le spectacle d'entrevue je
pense également de vous résilience et
défis de l'intégration d'un arabe au
québec l'autre chaîne au fus la semaine
passée s'est encore maryse il a déjà
participé à ces divisions
photo une époque celle où nous sommes
c'est ça la polémique alors les élevages
une émission 28 août à fait voilà c'est
pour vous renseigner sur ce qu'on
appelle temps 2 0
regarder la toute fin la vidéo vidéo la
virale des chorales chantent en arabe
aux chansons traditionnelles musulmanes
ça c'est un mariage ou une rencontre
entre le québec et puis une tradition
musulmane d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a un
petit peu de son qu'il raccrochait tout
ça on va vérifier attend dé voir je
pense qu'elles changent pas ce qu'il ya
de plus juste à temps
[Musique]
alors voilà à découvrir dans le sur le
site de la page de tam-tam canada cette
semaine on est prêt pour cette saab sas
bull ça déboule vita comme le troisième
jeu ces bruits 50 boul bon en 59 ans
branchés
alors on fait le tour parce que tous à
mentir combien il vous reste deux boules
combien la vue ou mais j'allais perdre
une fois donc je devrais tu as société
et se donner la réponse pas les détails
soixante six bons mois ses 55 ans 70 62
70 70 à 3 70 et moi cinq ans c'est la
tristesse excusez je pense qu'elle
reviendra pas les messieurs c'est pas
top
bin moi vous étiez la championne de
toutes les réponses mais bombay répondu
non mais je laisse du terrain aux autres
ou alors laisser une chance à ces gens
représentent la troisième question pour
le bénéfice de tous sur notre graphique
en 1 ça coûte rien c'est pas cher c'est
bien beau aujourd'hui sur la planète
quel pourcentage des musulmans ne sont
pas arabes ainsi que sa très bonne
question en effet spécialistes or il est
fréquent chez les occidentaux parce
qu'il m'a ici au québec loin les arabes
sont butés irlande par exemple
là c'est vraiment du pur hasard
non pas spécialement d'arabie tu as déjà
parce qu on n ose y a beaucoup de
musulmans là bas c'est en millions
centaines de millions
je remarque que vous laissez tous ce
samedi à s'exprimer n'est ce pas ce
qu'on voulait mais ces éléments et en
mutinerie dans son champ tout le monde
sait combien de voix écoutée on peut
aller à 55 pouces c'est à 75% à 55 % à
35 % ou 15 blanchit donc agir aux
smashes il y en a beaucoup en afrique
aussi c'est ça l'afrique la chine la
turquie et l'asie le monde arabe ces 200
millions de personnes les musulmans
européens milliards on est autour de la
paire le tout premier non attendez sur
un milliard on a 200 millions qui sont
dix secondes d'écouté et 10 ans qui est
75% mois gérer entre 75 et 21 55 je
pourrai pas les sauces et je sens qu
est-ce que de tout perdre
je suis comme celui entre 55,5 à 115,55
pour matthew g pas changé moi j'étais en
sorte que ces sacs ou 15 secondes à
temps ce n'est pas qui plus est en
difficulté ou gérer pour 50 75 75 jours
et pour ça je pense que c'est ce que le
match change d'idée parce que rien ne va
plus la boule tôt faites vos jeux c'est
75 75 et des faits sinon les autres
emballages non communiste alors on
confirme ce sens bien la regarder
l'idée c'est parce qu'il ya à peu près
un milliard et 200 millions d'arabes
donc serait pas et c'est ça qui est bien
il est très fréquent étant des acteurs
rafraîchit le monde arabe est pas très
grand du coup on le compare pour pièces
au milieu s'est passé encore récent du
mot énorme et c'est ce qui s'est passé
et qui est sorti avec un peu près qui a
bondi de 7 ans même confiance et ça et
on a beau habiter sur la question est
bon qu'un le coran a été publiée à
partir de la révélation révélation du
corbillard ya aussi une approche
féministe de la révélation est bon
augure à son bon on va pas s'envoyer des
fleurs un beau tapis persiennes non
voici 7e siècle je pense et puis on se
sent comme un là c'était avant les
conquêtes et ça se pouvait pas voilà
quand il ya eu les conquêtes et ont été
chercher des gens qui n'étaient pas
nécessairement donc il ya plus de gens
maintenant qu'ils sont là c'est un peu
comme en afrique du nord
ces musulmans mais c'est pas de souche
arabe ces berbères c'est un média de
mélanger à de ceux qui ont émigré donc
s'étaler sur le site de radio canada
international sous le premier anglais
quand vous a montré son atout c'est
spécial sur le monde arabe
vous avez retrouvé des cartes du monde
arabe et musulman aujourd'hui pourrait
faire une comparaison des deux voire les
on parlait de commandeur de direction qu
on était jeunes en mathématiques à
genoux à une fellation
oui ou non quand on regarde on sent
votre sexe non on va parler des grains
certes c'est sa confiance et que se
rejoignent elle s'appelait sa fonction
au csa
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas bon ok on est
prêt pour la nature ans et là quelle est
l'image la semaine n'y a pas de danse
avec la wii alors je réponds wafa oui ou
par non seulement aux camions
découverte également on sait pas pas
est-ce que c'est l'international
impressionnant sebastiana mais c'est pas
le camion ça ne se passe malheureusement
pas en reste ça ne concerne pas tremble
mali fouchy non sur l'amérique latine
non qu'est ce que c'est au canada non
pas parce que c'est pas les élections
c'est pâques en asie le cabinet et
montréal élections fédérales allemandes
a dit non maintenant réussi non respecté
non à la radio café non aux états unis
oui à ces états unis mais au moins pas
encore à propos de tout
non mais est ce que c'est la politique
non suspens l'environnement cmae
retourner aux états unis que tu sais pas
la prudence est pas un bilan 10 morts
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui reste est-ce
que c'est culturel pardon est-ce que
c'est culturel
non on en pense et croit qu'il faudra
attendre des etats-unis qui s'est pas
posé à vous aider
0 et 1
ah oui c'est l'ordinateur de goût
la solution expliquez-nous ça on va
prendre les yeux c'est compliqué à
expliquer et d'ailleurs une histoire
très drôle derrière tout ça c'est parce
que vous savez qu'il ya du coup ils sont
arrivés avec un papier en disant qu'ils
ont réussi à créer un ordinateur
quantique le faire fonctionner et il a
réussi à résoudre un problème en 200
secondes alors que le plus gros
ordinateurs moment le plus puissant
l'aurait fait il dit miller alors la
longue histoire qui est marrant c'est
que le premier plus gros ordinateurs du
monde c'est ibm qui l'a conçu que le
rival de des plots google 1
et en fait ibm a eu les mains sur le
papier en avance et deux jours avant la
sortie de ce papier sur l'ordinateur
quantique
ils ont révélé non c'est pas vrai notre
ordinateur aurait fait cette opération
en deux jours et demi afin qu est quand
même énorme différence entre 10000 ans
et deux jours et demi et en réponse
google a été très fair play et elle a
invité à venir le faire l'essai avec le
gougaud fair play pour essayer de voir
si c'est vrai qu'ils bm sont
l'ordinateur le plus puissant au monde
l'aurait fait en deux jours et demi deux
jours et demi alors comment ça
fonctionne l'ordinateur quantique
alors c'est compliqué à expliquer mais
un ordinateur classique ce marchand 1 à
0 d'accord ça s'enchaîne 1 0 1 0 1 0
l'ordinateur quantique a fait les deux
choses en même temps 0 1 en même temps
comme les femmes ont fait plusieurs
choses c'est à dire qu'il ne
s'enchaînent pas comme un ordinateur
classique c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
extrêmement plus vite
hélas cette fois ci ils ont réussi à
faire fonctionner une certaine gamme et
ils ont en fait fonctionne 56 sur 57
voix en même temps et ça mais on reste
quand même mort expérimental aux frais
du mental est là des scientifiques dans
ce domaine là sont très excités parce
que là ça ouvre tout sur deux
possibilités et j'entendais une autre
vie cette semaine à radio canada qui
disaient que je ne sera utilisé que pour
des trucs très précis de sciences par
les gouvernements
à de réussir à refaire l'opération c est
google a les fonds nécessaires ils ont
réussi à le faire parce qu'ils ont la
structure ils ont d'ailleurs travaillé
avec la nasa c'est pas juste google
alors avant que ça puisse être fait par
un autre organisme je pense que l'on va
attendre un petit peu de sa superbe
ça s'est passé un peu inaperçu ce passe
entre les branches et des élections
canada il ya des histoires avec 30 par
contre aux états unis vient chez moi
j'ai vu ça toutes deux reprises nous
n'en avons pas parlé parce que
malheureusement le canada n'était pas
impliqué dans ce projet là mais
radio-canada rendez-vous peut-être qu'à
d'électricité canadienne derrière ce
projet soit chaleur maintenant il va
falloir regarder la réponse de ibm as
simple as qui vont pas s'avouer vaincu
aussi facilement et ils savent eux aussi
sur le même projet et coup ils vont voir
ce qu'ils vont sortir mais il n'y a pas
je veux jouer marif ya pas de
possibilité d'accords de coopération
entre les 2 roues bien google veut
toujours être avoir la mainmise sur tout
je le fais poser la question c'est y
répondre
moi merci un aspect mercantile ah ça oui
quand on voit cet échange le de
l'histoire du papier qui est sorti avant
et comment ils ont voulu encore tout
changer en les déroutes ans et se montre
ça c'est ce qu'on sait pas ce qu'on sait
pas ce que la chine elle fait est
apparemment est en avance sur la chine
ça reste plus sucrés et hindi partage -
avec l'al l'amérique surtout avec ce qui
se passe en ce moment
le président américain et l'état chinois
oui les choses qui se passent oui sauf
que ce sont les gens de la guerre à dieu
merci beaucoup matthew d'être venu
aujourd'hui à l'émission
et puis maryse aussi marie jobin appui
alléchante inchangé à 6 merci à vous
également
est-ce qu'on a désigné donc un grand
gagnant pour l'émission aujourd'hui le
chapeau va'aa matthew à manier on est à
égalité
deux jeunes filles d'un côté les gars de
l'eau et j'ai remarqué je donnerai un
plus ha pour l'explication
si j'ai dû lire dessus quand même parce
que c'est un sujet compliqué et même les
premiers articles sont l'elysée il
fallait savoir fallait creuser pour
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et kate
a fait jeu attendez attendez vous quoi
quoi c'est loin mais c'est la position
des gens services techniques
heureusement et à la guerre et l affût
pardon mais on rappelle valérie donzelli
monde arabe se soit si vous êtes sur
montréal
t'en vas ou d'apprendre ça il ya aussi
au national mais dans les faits main
[Musique]